that's right she's back the world's
trumpiest judge judge Eileen Cannon is
back and this time it's to preside over
the criminal case against Donald J Trump
over his hoarding of National Defense
information in the southern district of
Florida judge Cannon was the Trump
appointee who intervened in the
documents Case by accepting jurisdiction
where none existed to put up roadblocks
against the government's investigation
in the pre-indictment stage her rulings
were so Bonkers at the conservative 11
circuit court of appeals took the case
away from her because she defied quote
our nation's foundational principle that
our law applies to all without regard to
numbers wealth or rank but now the judge
Cannon is back on the case is there
anything that prosecutor Jack Smith can
do about it or is he about to become
cannon fodder but first my eaglets we
need to think like a lawyer and figure
out how we got here in the first place
now after the FBI served a search
warrant on Mar-A-Lago Trump filed a
lawsuit seeking the appointment of a
special Master over the proceeding you
might recall that Trump filed the suit
in the Fort Pierce division in Florida
even though Mar-A-Lago is in the West
Palm Beach division because he wanted
judge Cannon to preside over it judge
Cannon agreed with Trump that a special
Master should be appointed to review
over 11 000 documents and 1800 items at
the FBI sees she also took the
extraordinary step of quote temporarily
enjoying the government from reviewing
and using the Seas materials for
investigative purposes pending
completion of the special Masters review
or further court order her order
effectively halted the government's
criminal investigation and government
appealed it in its entirety the
government also filed a separate motion
to stay the part of the ruling that
stopped the FBI from looking at the 103
documents with classified markings judge
Cannon denied the doj's motion rejecting
government's argument that Trump
couldn't assert executive privilege or
any other interest in the documents with
classified markings judge Cannon also
refused to accept that the documents
marked classified were necessarily
classified
Come On Eileen I swear at this moment
the doj appealed and in September the
11th circuit issued a partial stay of
her order prohibiting the government
from reviewing documents marked as
classified the unanimous opinion
thoroughly rebuked judge Cannon for her
ruling saying quote we cannot discern
why plaintiff would have an individual
interest in or need for any of the 100
documents with classification markings
and in December the 11th circuit found
that Canon never should have exercised
jurisdiction and the panel vacated judge
Canon's order excoriating her for
implying that special rules apply to
Trump quote we cannot write a rule that
allows any subject of a search warrant
to block government investigations after
the execution of the warrant nor can we
write a rule that allows only foreign
presidents to do so this was a fancy way
of saying that judge Cannon was
um not acting as she should have you
know you know them right it truly was an
extraordinary opinion from a panel of
conservative judges against one of their
own so now judge Cannon's assignment as
trial judge has some people wondering if
the process is rigged we have a rigged
Country Now Under The District Court's
procedures new cases are randomly given
to a judge who sits in the division
where the matter arose or a neighboring
one now the New York Times asked Angela
Noble the chief Clerk of the southern
district of Florida whether normal
procedures were followed and whether
judge Candice assignment was random she
said quote normal procedures were
followed now Noble explained that
Mar-A-Lago is in the West Palm Beach
division between the Fort Lauderdale
Division and the Fort Pierce division
where judge Cannon sits The District
Court's website shows that seven active
judges have Chambers in those three
divisions as do three judges on senior
status who still hear cases now Noble
said that certain factors increase judge
Cannon's chances quote for one senior
judges are removed from the case
assignment system or wheel once they
fulfill their target caseload for the
year at least one of the senior judges
is done as she added that quote she was
highly confident that the other two are
very likely at their target too
furthermore she went on to say that one
of the seven active judges with Chambers
in Fort Lauderdale is now a Miami judge
for the perfect of assignments and
another is not currently receiving cases
but what about Judge Middlebrooks who
earlier this year ordered Trump to pay
nearly a million dollars for filing a
frivolous lawsuit against Hillary
Clinton Noble said that judge
Middlebrooks draws 50 percent of his
criminal cases from the Miami Division
and that decreased his odds in contrast
judge Cannon quote draws 50 of her cases
from West Palm Beach increasing her
chances so there you go sometimes things
can be random and fate just has a sense
of humor happy Hunger Games
and may the arms be ever in your favor
so let's talk about how and when judges
who are assigned can be disqualified now
judicial impartiality is one of the
Bedrock principles of the rule of law
litigants have a 14th Amendment right to
a quote neutral and detached judge and
when a party believes the judge may not
be impartial the remedy is to move to
disqualify the judge from the case now
the primary source of disqualification
is 28 USC 455 which says in relevant
part quote any justice shall disqualify
himself in any proceeding in which his
impartiality might reasonably be
questioned he shall also disqualify
himself in the following circumstances
one where he has a personal bias or
Prejudice concerning a party or personal
knowledge of disputed evidentiary facts
concerning the proceeding now the
standard for disqualification is whether
quote a reasonable objective person
knowing all the circumstances would have
questioned the judge's impartiality and
many people say that the 11th circuit
Smackdown of Judge Cannon proves that
she is biased in favor of trump now the
implication in the 11th circuit's ruling
was that Canon made up a rule that would
let the cranky ex president stop a
criminal investigation because of
personal favoritism but that's not
necessarily evidence of personal bias
the Supreme Court has held that quote
judicial rulings alone almost never
constitute a valid basis for a bias or
partiality motion the Supreme Court also
said the quote judicial remarks made
during the course of a trial that are
critical or disproving of or even
hostile to counsel the parties or their
cases ordinarily do not support a bias
or partiality challenge so even if the
judge made a ruling that was overturned
on appeal and even if the judge made
remarks that were hostile to the
government's case that isn't necessarily
enough to warrant recusal on its own and
the Supreme Court also said the quote
judicial remarks made during the course
of a trial that are critical or
disapproving of or even hostile to
counsel the parties or their cases
ordinarily do not support a bias or
partiality challenge so even if the
judge made a ruling that was overturned
on appeal and even if the judge made
remarks that were hostile to the
government's case that isn't enough to
warrant recusal on its own but on top of
that as many people have pointed out
judge Cannon was appointed to the bench
by then president Trump does that form
the basis of emotion to disqualify well
the Supreme Court has never ruled that a
federal judge should be disqualified
from ruling on a matter that involves a
president who appointed them federal
judges in fact hear all sorts of cases
involving the actions of the president
or their Administration although usually
those matters involve the legality of
the president's legislative or executive
actions and not whether the president
individually should go to prison or not
now if you ever find yourself in a
lawsuit dealing with an unreasonable
judge you're definitely going to need a
great lawyer and it's great news because
my firm the eagle team is now accepting
new clients if you've ever been in a car
crash suffered from police brutality or
sexual harassment or just about anything
else we can represent you or help find
the right attorney who can just click on
the link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team so just click on the link
below now back to judge Cannon now judge
Cannon could recuse herself to sponte
meaning on her own volition if she
wanted to but let's assume that she
decides to remain as trial judge could
the case be reassigned anyway
some commentators including former U.S
attorney for the Northern District of
Alabama Joyce Vance thinks that that's
the case she points to a case called U.S
versus Martin in which the 11th circuit
ruled that even though there was no
indication of actual bias a criminal
case should be reassigned to a different
judge in that particular case the court
had to reverse the trial judge's
sentencing determination twice the court
said that it also reversed that judge in
three other cases for quote
extraordinary downward departures that
were without a valid basis in the record
so in light of his prior action the
court of appeals felt that the judge
would have difficulty putting his
previous views and findings aside and
that seems to fit with most of the times
that the court of appeals tends to
intervene it's repeated misconduct from
a particular judge and the two times
that judge Cannon has been rebuked by
the 11th circuit in this particular case
uh are pretty individualized and may not
rise to that particular standard and of
course it's possible that the Jack Smith
in the Department of Justice could move
to disqualify judge Cannon I'm going to
request that you disqualify yourself
from sitting on this case I'm going to
take a transcript of the trial to the
judicial conduct board and ask that they
impeach your ass generally speaking the
Department of Justice is loathe to try
to kick judges off of their cases
because they are repeat players and they
don't want to piss off any particular
judge they might be in front of again
though at the same time this might be
one of those cases where they want to
roll those dice so the next question is
if judge Cannon remains on the case how
much power would she have here well the
answer is a lot now Trump would
obviously prefer to delay the
proceedings as long as possible until he
is potentially elected president again
and you know might pardon himself and
Canon can play along with that plan
quite a bit if she wants to in an
extreme case judge Cannon can also just
dismiss the case before trial and of
course there are a million different
pre-trial decisions that a trial judge
has to make before it gets to trial for
example there's bound to be a fight over
the use of Trump's attorneys notes which
contain Communications between Trump and
his attorney which of course were
allowed to be used in the run-up to the
indictment because another Court found
that the crime fraud exception applied
and breached the attorney-client
privilege and if judge Cannon ruled to
exclude this or any other kind of
evidence the standard is extremely
favorable to the trial judge effectively
the government would have to prove that
the judge abused their discretion in
disallowing the evidence and that's a
really high burden to get over and if
she lets the trial go ahead Donald Trump
could file for a rule 29 motion that
would allow the judge to enter a
judgment of acquittal if the judge
believed that the evidence was
insufficient to sustain a conviction and
that ruling would be unappealable and
double jeopardy would attach the judge
can do this at the close of the
government's evidence after the jury
makes up its decision or for up to 14
days after a guilty verdict though if
she acquitted Trump after the jury found
him guilty the government might have a
limited right to appeal but only on the
issue of whether there should be a new
trial and in terms of real punishments
for malfeasance from the judge in this
kind of a situation the options are
really Slim judge Cannon has been
appointed to the federal bench for life
and she can only be removed through
impeachment in the house and conviction
in the Senate which is obviously
extraordinarily rare though there is
another option trial judges generally
hate being reversed by the court of
appeals and it's possible that after
being rebuked by the 11th circuit twice
judge Cannon has learned her lesson and
will play this one straight it's also
possible that seeing the allegations and
the evidence before her in this
particular case she would play it more
Straight Ahead than what she did in the
prior pre-indictment case uh itself but
given the prior shenanigans that we saw
I wouldn't necessarily hold my breath on
that particular take additionally
Florida isn't the only jurisdiction that
could hear the documents case Federal
prosecutors are required to present
cases for indictment in a district where
the alleged offense occurred in the
documents case there was relevant
conduct that occurred in Washington DC
the end Bedminster New Jersey as well as
Florida though obviously most of it
happened in Florida and venue in Florida
makes sense because the majority of the
action took place there and prosecutors
probably picked Florida to avoid a fight
with Trump over a proper venue however
uh prosecutor Smith could still bring a
documents case in potentially Washington
DC or New Jersey as some of Trump's
conduct did happen in those locations as
well you know if there are additional
crimes that have not yet been charged
but the bottom line is that Canon is
going to need to find her voice is she
going to issue Lawless crazy rulings
like in the Warren proceedings or act
like a normal sane judge and she can do
that with today's sponsor skillshare and
particularly Nathaniel Drew's great
class creativity Unleashed discover hone
and share your voice online Nathaniel is
one of my favorite online creators and
in his skillshare class he'll guide
judge Cannon through determining her
individual value as a Creator overcoming
insecurities establishing her Core theme
and evolving her work as she grows all
important lessons for a federal judge or
anyone looking to explore their own
creative and career goals skillshare as
you probably know is one of the world's
largest online learning communities with
tens of thousands of classes on almost
everything you may know skillshare for
their classes in photography film and
video editing and illustration but they
also have hundreds of career Focus
classes as well so if you'd like to try
out skillshare the first 1000 legal
eaglets to use my link in the
description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium and for a limited
time that trial is for an entire month
not just 14 days as usual all you have
to do is click on the link on screen or
down in the description so for a free
one month subscription to skillshare
just click on the link below and then
after that click on this link over here
for more legal eagle where I'll see you
in court